[Music]
stranger things 3 is right around the
corner and if the trailer promises
anything it's a summer that we won't
forget with the show due to drop in the
next few months I decided to do a
breakdown of everything we know so far
about the season including its release
date plot details and more this is full
spoilers ahead so if you want to go into
season 3 with fresh eyes then I highly
recommend that you turn off now with
that out the way
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I explain it so you don't
have to do stranger things 3 is due to
release on Netflix worldwide on the 4th
of July the show will be set during the
summer of 1985 and this Independence Day
release will likely feature in the show
itself the last time we saw the gang was
Halloween 2017 and this release was
mirrored by the time setting of the show
so it makes sense that season 3 drops on
Netflix at this time too so what about
the plot well whilst the recently
released trailer was pretty sparse on
plot details there were huge hints
towards the budding relationship between
Mike and Eleven who produces of the show
the duffl brothers are affectionately
calling m---eleven the characters went
through another year and because of this
time jump the show will pick up with
them afar on from the events of season 2
the characters are now entering high
school for the first time and season 3
will center around the implications that
come with this this is going to
definitely be a coming-of-age story and
we may see the group becoming divided
due to their changes in personality the
teenage angst is showcased in the
trailer when Finn states we're not kids
anymore which he then follows up with I
mean what did you think we were just
going to sit in my basement all day play
video games for the rest of our lives I
was kind of hoping they were to be
honest but I guess not and this lines
inclusion clearly shows that we're going
to be dealing with the difficult teenage
years that have the potential to push
them further apart from one another
whilst this is going to throw a few
spanners in the work there's also the
fact that the shadow monster from season
2 has a vendetta against 11 and Beyond
stranger things Millie Bobby Brown who
plays the
character stated that she's screwed
which is pretty revealing as to its
return and goals and what about the new
monster that we see in the trailer
well each season features a monster that
the group end up naming after Dungeons &
Dragons creatures season 1 was the
demagogue in season 2 the mine player
and thus it makes sense that this new
season will pull from that as well
fans of the board game franchise have
flooded the internet with their theories
and the most likely one seems to be that
it is the terrace it's pretty close in
appearance and this monster is based
around a giant they said that possesses
several spikes and sharp terrifying
teeth which this appears to have there's
even a theory that one of the characters
could be this creature which I'll go
into later in the video so what about
the new characters well whilst the
original gang are returning there are
also several additions to the cast
Maya Hall is cast as Robin who is
Steve's co-worker at the ice-cream
parlor scoops ahoy in the new Hawkins
mall the mall is set to be the new
hangout area for the group and it
features prominently in the trailer as
this will be their go-to area Jake Busey
has also been cast as a journalist who
may be chronicling the strange things
that have been in the town Carey ELLs is
also appearing as mayor Kline who is
described as being more focused on his
image than the people of Hawkins this
will most likely riff on jaws and we
will see an inept leader who doesn't
really know how to handle the monsters
that star appearing in the town and
therefore gets out stood when it comes
to the crunch by Jim Hoppa played by
David Harper Joyce and hopper are to set
to build a relationship in this season
and obviously the two have known each
other for a long time been through a lot
and thus this makes a lot of sense this
is also set to be mirrored in the
relationship of Nancy and Jonathan Nancy
seems to have chosen him over Steve
however the latter gave her a look in
the last season's finale that makes me
believe that things aren't necessarily
over between them Joe Keary who plays
Steve recently stated in an interview
with he online that I don't think it's
the end of the story but I do think that
the second season was a lot about him
growing up and learning how to put
people before him a little bit more I
don't think it's over I think how they
leave it is realistic so it seems that
the love triangles that the show is
built upon will continue throughout this
and Nancy may even go back to
since he became the world's best
babysitter in season two Billy and Erica
are too set to get bigger roles this
season the former was originally meant
to be a large part of season two however
due to the amount of characters the
duffer brothers had to cut much of his
arc this season is set to remedy that
with the character getting much more
development it appears that he's getting
closer to Karen wheeler aka Mike's mum
with his job as a lifeguard and this
again will add to the dynamic
relationships of the show though that
may get cut short with the appearance of
the Tarasque now this isn't confirmed
but we see shots in the trailer that
show Billy seems to be infected with
something the character did get stabbed
with the same syringe that was used to
sedate will who has long been tainted by
the upside down and this
cross-contamination that may now be
affecting Billy many think that Billy
may in fact be the Tarasque and this
would make sense as to why the creature
appears in the hospital in the trailer
perhaps Billy was rushed there before
transforming and then the infection took
over and changed him finally what's the
future of the show beyond this season
well according to the duffer brothers
stranger things will be the penultimate
season with the show coming to a close
in season Paul that still gives us a lot
to look forward to but it is a bit sad
that we won't get to see the cast of
characters beyond that season anyway
that's everything we know so far about
stranger things season 3 and obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
show and if you have any other theories
in regards to the cast monsters and more
make sure you leave them in the comments
below and if you like this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out my breakdown of this
week's other big release us which will
be linked at the end this is the channel
for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]
you